- Welcome to Connecticut.
And welcome to my forge.
I'm Brian Evelich,
and I've been bladesmithing
for about
a year and a quarter.
Everything in my forge has a
story.
My coal forge was a gift
from a friend
who was getting rid of an old
barbecue.
And I welded it in a basin,
and I did an air injection
system using steel piping.
Later on, about six months
later,
I decided I needed
a propane forge.
And I welded together a frame
with fire brick,
and I made my own propane
forge.
When I first started
making knives,
I was using the bumper
on the back of my truck
as an anvil because I didn't
have anything else.
And I put a Facebook post out,
and a high school friend
responded that he had an anvil
sitting in his garage.
As it turns out,
I find out later,
it was used to make horseshoes
for Washington's army
as they crossed
through central New Jersey
back during
the Revolutionary War.
Up here are just some
of the blades I've made
that I felt were noteworthy,
and I've kept around.
I love the kukri episodes. The
shapes just really thrill me.
So I tried to make a couple
of kukri
just to kind of have
around the shop.
- I'm Deke Parker,
and I'm from Elkhart, Kansas.
This is my shop.
I usually run this two-burner
propane forge.
Bought this forge when I was
ten years old.
I was actually forging with a
torch before that,
so I was about nine when I
started--nine and ten.
Over here this is my--it's
about 125 pounds,
plus the chain--Acme anvil.
Funny story on that.
That actually came out of my
boss's backyard.
He just give it to me.
This is my main workbench
right here.
This is where most of my handle
gluing and all that stuff
goes on.
Oh, and that over there, that's
my sledge block.
These are pretty hard to find
nowadays.
They're rare.
And this big guy, this is my
big drill press.
This actually came off a World
War II submarine.
This thing's heavy.
It--it took a lot of work to
get it in here.
♪ ♪
- This is a gifted motor off
of an old Whirlpool tub.
And so I've been using that for
about ten months now
on this angle grinder.
Carrying on the trend of
recycled and gifted items,
this was in a dump
being discarded.
Turns out, the top was just
full of bird's nests
from being outside, so it
didn't require much
to get it back running,
but it's very low torque.
This is my shop.
This is my forge.
Thank you for doing
a walkthrough.
I'm really excited
to have you come visit.
♪ ♪
- Come here, Whiskers.
[whistles]
Hey.
I like dogs.
These are my three good ones,
though.
They go everywhere.
What you doing?
Hey.
Spud.
Down.
♪ ♪
Stay.
That's pretty much the forging
area of my shop right there.
You'll find me on Facebook
and... [laughs]
I'll build you a knife, or you
can come out and visit.
I like visitors.
[chuckles]
♪ ♪